dis la vérité dit ce qui doit l et
naulleau déjà question pensent marga
naulleau fidèles bat valérie j'aime
aller les thèmes bien je devais imprimé
léopard c'est magnifique
ah ouais bah ouais c'est bien ah ouais
j'aime bien mais pas vous mettre un pôle
à tout ça et eric naulleau
mais christina ici on dit les choses non
si tu trouve quelqu'un dégueulasse tu
dis les dégâts la tuerie mal fans des
bulls
[Applaudissements]
tu peux dire tu peux dire ce que tu peux
dire à manille laical a décollé vers ces
métiers là bonjour
et si la ligne est à lyon x et puis
c'est 6 4 veste noire est aussi bleu
marine c'est plus chic mais bon le noir
si c'est un bleu nuit
bon avec la petite pochette c'est bien
la chimie s'est bien fait rire c'est
bien mais bon les baskets on pouvait
mieux faire
il a donné au pied
[Applaudissements]
lui regardez là ici là ici je ne sais
pas un oignon et lines la tâche il a
dans le même temps la tunisie la dune
show qui donc ni même erreur alors 0
avec deux occasions franches mais sinon
elle allait appeler les baskets plus il
est pour moi tu es sûr pourquoi tu te
perds pas de temps et je vais le faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très commenté de même sur dix a
dit vas t'asseoir ah bon ben c'est parti
sur dix jours donne un set à tous et
permet ou la bible h
sur la terre avec le mannequin et assure
la redoute vraiment il n'y a tenu alors
vous mettez je voudrais le tee shirt
jaune
ouais maman prends-moi également la
somme gelée est trop clair c'est la
rentrée scolaire question porte je peux
voir que ces matches là on s'appelait ça
veut dire je vous plaît je sais chérie
ma je pense qu'on pouvait mieux faire
j'aime bien le côté super position mais
c'est peut-être la couleur des t-shirts
voie métrique ou des gaules ait dit la
vérité du shopping c'est tous les jours
ainsi je suis fou chat et misogyne les
rênes du shopping tous les jours sur m6
regarder s'il adore aller bien sûr je te
jure que c'est vrai moi j'adore les
rênes du shopping bonjour libye edition
ou deux discours qui dit non mais dis la
vérité note soumise et c'est pas parce
que c'est quelqu'un peut pas dire
qu'elle est toute mignonne
moi j'aime bien moi j'aime bien le les
cuisses à se relever
je suis j'aime bien la petite jupe les
petiots en revanche je ne suis pas fan
le ta gueule couleur chair à l'école en
couleur chair n'allait pas pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi dis moi ça pour quoi
pour les téléspectatrices qui nous
regardent pourquoi mais les loups et les
téléspectatrices elles savent pourquoi
le cool c'est déjà assez d appel
internationale contre les parents parce
qu est le légume
mais pourquoi parce que le colon qu'on
leur chance est pas d'actualité c'est
plus que le renouvellement matin des
grands mères il aurait fallu que m
nouveau maire louis tu vois ça fait un
peu trop classique
si on va aller peut-être voir l'aréna
d'atteindre la terre et que tu portes
une jupe sans que l'on relate merchat
mais pour les salles
photo m tu aurais tu te pointes de
l'unacois lanvin derniers mois avant le
maire les crochets sétois et roger
tallon leurs hanches et saisir les
patientes et voilà la wii donc le vin
s'est tous sentis mais en collants noirs
c'est mieux que le colloque au large
alors moi je veux dire la vérité tu sais
quoi et en tant qu'homme je dis la
vérité
oui et le fallait on ne savait pas moi
j'adore les colons couleur chair ah bah
oui parce que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi alors l'attelage est là je
vais te léger et des notes non des
volailles soumaré si bon donc alors les
médias m comment tu mettais à lui j'ai
vu que tu comme youtube et c'est donc
lui qu'on 2,5 et la dame je mettrais
ainsi c'est ce que le coin pour la
recherche mais ça tape ça peut y perdre
des points c'est pas la première fois
allez on va mal on va enchaîner avec la
plus mauvaise note
si tu veux te lever comme pour à kelly
tu peux te c'est pas si mal aujourd'hui
c'est pas si les toits je trouve que
c'est bien c'est pas si mauvais mais on
peut mieux faire chier fait qu est ce qu
il aurait fallu qu'il fasse celui ci
mais j'aimerais bien lui vaut avant tout
le monde on autre registre on la voyait
quelque chose de plus que la cgem arrivé
à baby erreur en costume armani
oui mais quoi les salariés des sorciers
le week-end le sol et se dirigea
week-end c'est bien que ça le week end
dans une interview conduite par là je
les mets en dessous de la moyenne locale
holloway je me crée à 4,19 chez des
volailles il n'est pas déjà catégorique
[Rires]
choquée je voudrais bien te voir avec
notre part du chic ça va changer des
habitudes chéri le servir a dit jim
freeman the dawn addiego mal au genou
dgo par contre si j'étais toi je ferme
le rideau à brax get right man car
bouton avait lui-même est passé mon fils
à vassieux libre et moi j'ai l'oeil mois
n'est pas dégueulasse pas dégueulasse et
compliquée des biens trace une super
efficace le jeans dr les jeans délavés
tendance
il a 17 juin et saïdou là ça va
s'arrêter au monsieur là alors mais on
était passé c'est vrai il est dépassé
quand tu es beau tu es beau mais moi je
le trouve bien n'être voilà en plus apte
à maigrir ou non les yeux des yeux mes
baskets blanches sans moi tu y vois la
météo je ne donne pas ma mère
du coup oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est quelqu'un qui s'habillaient mais
qui fait des travaux c'est une personne
devait dès lors qu isabelle c'est aussi
et coloré elle est mon côté ça tu es
déçu du manque de crédibilité à t'en
sortir
maj et parce que honnêtement je pense
que j'aime bien j'aimerais bien te
regarder dans un autre registre mais
dans une autre émission mais j'aime
bientôt 10 talent mais on peut je
voudrais voir différentes mais sait on a
envie mais quoi tu en vue de la relooker
sallaoui allait jamais un relooking
express page wiki express avec vous de
là je voudrais si cette ligne est mince
entre les seychelles camionneurs tout le
temps toi
[Rires]
alors matthieu delormeau vers le métier
de mannequin
moi
alors oui la vérité j'ai voulu dire
qu'il est dégueulasse honnêtement je
trouve pas ça mauvais pas mauvais tout
je trouve pas ça m'en vais c'est une
gifle et chaussures laissées là j'aime
bien le côté pull avec ma chemise à
carreaux à l'epa rock et baroque
il est bas en tout cas combien je te
donne en sait
m
[Applaudissements]
allez renonce à demander c'est pas là
pour être je vais konan et je vais quand
même lui montrer par action voilà on a
dans les stades les hommes à la vaysse
inspiration smoking canada et puis et
puis le collier au toit en dur en 20
trous du cul tout mayol et j'adore c'est
vrai avril est vraiment très très très
bon ok je le donne bien avant
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait beaucoup trop une red bull